[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fifteen years 15 years connecting the
disconnected 15 years believing in a
revolutionary future
fifteen years accelerating ubiquitous
full fiber connectivity we have created
a momentum around fiber helped bring
about a sustainable future full of
opportunity all enabled by
fiber-to-the-home connectivity which
brings a better quality of life
an increased economic competitiveness
all because of you the members and
supporters of the FDD page Council
Europe you are the engine that feels
[Music]
you the technology innovators the
disruptors the fiber operators the
investors the fibre pioneers with more
than 150 members and many more partners
we are promoting full fiber high speed
connectivity for everyone everything
everywhere together
we find out our future and the future is
bright
5g virtual reality visual recognition
systems artificial intelligence
revolutionary developments in health
smart cities and homes and having
glimpsed the future the opportunities
are endless fiber is needed everywhere
and it is you that will deliver this
vision are you in or before you in my
fellow fiber-to-the-home Council
colleagues are you in everybody else is
everybody in
you